[Música]
[Aplausos]
Cómo hacer que sea imping ponga de una
vez por todas fin a su política de
confrontación con los países
democráticos como diantres podemos
evitar que el régimen totalitario de
Pekín se convierta en un riesgo y una
amenaza para todos queridos amigos
amigas hoy más que nunca estas preguntas
están de máxima actualidad
china ha experimentado un enorme cambio
tras décadas de rápido crecimiento y
modernización tecnológica productiva y
militar por el régimen de sillín está
obsesionado con una idea convertir a
China en el nuevo hegemon mundial la
nueva superpotencia capaz de rivalizar
con los Estados Unidos quieren acabar
con la hegemonía de occidente para
lograr que Pekín se convierta en la
nueva capital de referencia
internacional
precisamente por eso bajo el gobierno
del partido comunista china Está
tratando de incrementar su influencia
política económica militar Y hasta
Cultural El problema que china sigue
siendo una dictadura totalitaria y Eso
debería de preocuparnos a todos sobre
todo cuando simppin está desarrollando
una agenda cada vez más y más hostil
queréis algunos ejemplos pues veamos
[Música]
Estoy totalmente seguro de que la
inmensa mayoría de vosotros habéis oído
hablar del famoso globo chino que
sobrevoló Estados Unidos y que fue
descubierto mientras sobrevolaba una
instalación de misiles balísticos
nucleares en Montana un globo que
finalmente fue destruido por un f-22 un
globo que según parece portaba antenas y
sensores para recopilar inteligencia e
interceptar comunicaciones de hecho
según ha confirmado el departamento de
estado norteamericano el propio
fabricante de globo tiene una relación
directa con el ejército chino el globo
chino llevaba antenas y otros equipos
para recabar información según Estados
Unidos según un funcionario Estados
Unidos se prepara para tomar medidas
contra entidades vinculadas al programa
chino de vigilancia de globos y para
colmo hemos sabido que no se trata de un
caso aislado ahora sabemos que podemos
encontrar muchos más casos al parecer se
trata de una flota de globos y aparatos
supuestamente espías que operan en los
cinco continentes incluyendo ya lo veis
Estados Unidos lo que evidentemente
supone una Clara preocupación Claro que
los globos no son lo más peligroso ni
provocador del espionaje Chino los
ataques son muchísimo peores y sabéis
que llevan años siendo tan frecuentes
que en 2014 el propio director del FBI
James cómic diciendo que hay dos tipos
de grandes empresas en los Estados
Unidos las que han sido hackeadas por
los chinos y las que no saben que han
sido hackeadas por los chinos
Y es que veréis los ciberespias del
gigante asiático han atacado
sistemáticamente a los Estados Unidos
robándole al gobierno y a las empresas
norteamericanas planos diseños
industriales secretos comerciales y todo
tipo de información confidencial Incluso
se han hecho con material clasificado de
proyectos tan importantes como el F 35
lo que evidentemente como os podéis
imaginar pues no hace ninguna gracia en
Washington os acordáis de cuando el
gobierno de Estados Unidos dejó de
comprar dispositivos de Huawei y pidió a
las empresas norteamericanas que no
usaran sus productos pues este fue
exactamente el motivo ahora bien el
creciente choque entre China Estados
Unidos y la comunidad de las democracias
liberales va mucho más allá del
espionaje la agenda de confrontación de
Pekín también está detrás de noticias
como esta sin ayuda la guerra de Rusia
en Ucrania según muestran los datos
comerciales a pesar de las sanciones
Moscú y equipa sus cazas a reacción
submarinos y soldados con la ayuda de
compañía chinas china no solo no ha
secundado las sanciones sino que como
gesto está enviando a Rusia entre otros
componentes equipos de navegación para
los helicópteros m-17 de Rusia equipos
de interferencia de Comunicaciones y
piezas que pueden ser utilizadas en los
cazas sub 35 todo esto sigue en no muy
grandes y por qué decimos que esto es
una especie de provocación
Pues porque y ojo que esto es lo más
interesante no se trata de envíos
masivos si china quisiera podría
suministrar a Rusia grandes cantidades
de armamento si quisiera pero como ya os
contamos aquí visualpolitik no parece
que quiera ni arriesgarse con ella un
choque masivo con occidente Así que lo
que parece que están haciendo es enviar
equipos que les permitan quedar bien con
Moscú al tiempo que marcan su distancia
con Estados Unidos la Unión Europea y el
resto de países aliados para ello envían
sobre todo equipos de doble uso es decir
que pueden ser utilizados tanto para
fines militares como civiles pero sea
como sea esto está ayudando a Rusia y es
un gesto además que deja muy pero que
muy claro que mañana su posición podría
cambiar es otro gesto desafiante más y
No aún no hemos terminado
luego tenemos lo ocurrido con Hong Kong
y sobre todo las constantes amenazas
sobre Taiwán amenazas que se ha
multiplicado en los últimos años y que
han hecho incluso que altos oficiales
del ejército de Estados Unidos estén
alertando de que la invasión de La Isla
podría producirse mucho antes de lo que
cualquiera hubiera podido imaginar
globos espías ciberataques colaboración
con Rusia ocupación de Hong Kong y las
amenazas constantes a Taiwán y también a
otros muchos países como lituania el
resultado es que la agenda de sgpín la
verdad tiene una política exterior mucho
más activa y hostil con lo que podríamos
denominar como el mundo libre y la
pregunta es qué demonios se puede hacer
para frenar a Pekín Qué medidas podría
tomar Estados Unidos para castigar o
evitar este tipo de situaciones y ojo
que no es una pregunta menor es una de
las preguntas más importantes de nuestro
tiempo y sabéis que justo aquí surge la
hipótesis de las sanciones puede
frenarse la agenda imperialista de
jijing Pink sanciones económicas y se
instala la mejor forma de enfrentarse al
gigante asiático en este vídeo queridos
amigos amigas vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero lo primero de todo es
saber de qué hablamos exactamente
atentos
el castigo económico
son Realmente útiles y eficaces las
sanciones económicas sirven para algo
ojo que este no es un debate
precisamente nuevo existe desde por lo
menos hace 2500 años de hecho uno de las
primeras paquetes de sanciones
económicas de los que se tiene
constancia es el conocido como decreto
de megara en el año 432 antes de Cristo
fijaos ha llovido con este decreto
Atenas prohibió el comercio con megara y
prohibió los comerciantes de esta última
ciudad el acceso a los puertos
atenienses lo que para muchos fue la
causa principal que alimentó la guerra
del peloponeso
[Música]
mucho más recientemente la Sociedad De
Naciones sancionó por ejemplo Italia en
1935 por la invasión de la región
etíopedia visinia pocos años después
Estados Unidos hizo lo propio con el
Imperio de Japón y con la Alemania del
Tercer Reich pero sobre todo las
sanciones empezaron a cobrar más y más
peso A partir de los años 50 y sobre
todo se multiplicaron tras los atentados
del 11 de septiembre desde la Sudáfrica
de la parte al Irán de los ayatolas
pasando por el Isis la correa de Kim
Jong el régimen de gadafi o incluso el
Cartel de Cali
[Música]
en este gráfico podéis ver bien claro
como los castigos económicos han hecho
cada vez más y más populares por
supuesto y seguro que esto no sorprende
a nadie estos castigos económicos han
sido liderados por Estados Unidos
aprovechando el peso mundial que tiene
tanto el dólar como su sistema
financiero
este por ejemplo es el gráfico que
aglutina las sanciones de Estados Unidos
contra países empresas individuos de
todos los rincones del planeta fijaos
Cómo ha evolucionado en los últimos 20
años y desde luego se incluyéramos 2022
el gráfico se dispararía muchísimo más
porque por supuesto como todos
absolutamente todos sabéis el último
gran programa de sanciones masivas es
precisamente el que tiene que ver con la
Rusia de Putin tras la invasión de
Ucrania ahora bien la pregunta es
funcionan estas sanciones pues depende
de cómo se mire en un pasado vídeo aquí
en visualpolitik ya os mostramos como
las sanciones a Rusia sí que están
consiguiendo logros muy importantes
Aunque tengamos la sensación de que no
han conseguido tumbar la economía rusa
de hecho para evitar daños importantes
en la economía mundial las sanciones
suelen dirigirse a Campos muy concretos
es decir que casi pueden verse como
ataques quirúrgicos esa es al menos la
tendencia de los últimos años en el caso
de Rusia sin ir más lejos hablamos de
ataques contra su sistema financiero los
ingresos del gobierno su industria
tecnológica y militar y la inversión
extranjera de esta forma lo que se está
haciendo es intentar causar el mayor
daño posible a medio plazo sin por
ejemplo reventar el mercado energético
mundial eso es lo que explica también
que se haya fijado un tope al precio del
petróleo ruso en lugar de prohibir todo
el comercio petróleo ruso pero un
momento porque a ver hablar de China y
de sanciones no es como hablar de Rusia
con la del Norte Irán o prácticamente
cualquier otro país hablar de China son
palabras mayores Así que la pregunta es
se puede sancionar a China y de poder
serviría para algo pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
se puede sancionar a China
Estados Unidos y China se llevan peor
que en cualquier otro momento de las
últimas décadas prácticamente desde que
Richard Nixon puso en marcha el deshielo
político allá por 1972 las cosas no iban
tan mal entre estas dos potencias y eso
a pesar de que las dos economías de
estos dos gigantes están mucho más
unidas que en cualquier otro momento
histórico fijaos el comercio entre
Estados Unidos y China alcanzó un récord
en 2022 a pesar hablamos de un
gigantesco volumen comercial de algo más
de 690 mil millones de dólares y quizás
precisamente por eso en los últimos años
una pregunta está recibiendo todo el
protagonismo si las relaciones
económicas son tan importantes se puede
sancionar a China se puede utilizar la
guerra económica para debilitar al
gigante asiático y lograr Queen y su
camarilla desistan de su agenda tan
hostil y ojo porque esto es en cierto
modo exactamente lo que se está haciendo
empezó con Donald Trump con su famosa y
muy mal planteada guerra comercial y
ahora la administración vaivén Está
siguiendo unos pasos muy parecidos
especialmente lo que respecta a la
tecnología fijaos el día 16 de
septiembre del 2022 el asesor de
seguridad Nacional de Joe biden y un
importante discurso en el cambio los
objetivos de la seguridad Nacional de
Estados Unidos de apostar por tener una
cierta ventaja relativa sobre sus
rivales básicamente china a querer
lograr que esta ventaja sea lo más
grande posible de esta forma la
estrategia de seguridad Nacional de
Estados Unidos ya no se limita a querer
liberar sino que ahora en términos
tecnológicos y respecto a China quiere
apabullar es decir quiere ir muy por
delante cueste lo que cueste y eso es
exactamente lo que explica noticias como
estas 7 de octubre de 2022 la
Administración vaiden toma medidas
drásticas contra el acceso de China la
tecnología de chips la Casa Blanca
impuso amplias restricciones a la venta
de semiconductores y equipos de
fabricación de chips a China en un
intento de frenar el acceso de este país
a tecnologías críticas
9 de octubre de 2022 Estados Unidos
pretende restringir la inversión
tecnológica en China la administración
vaivén prepara nuevas normas que
restringirían el flujo de dólares a
China hablamos de un tipo de medidas que
recientemente se han visto fortalecidas
Mirad 30 de enero de 2023 Japón y los
Países Bajos se suman a las
restricciones de Estados Unidos a China
estos son los tres países que hoy por
hoy dominan la producción de equipos de
fabricación de Microchips de alta gama
Así que en cierto modo esto es una
sanción Estados Unidos está impidiendo
la venta China de los diseños y la
producción de los Microchips más
avanzados y también de las máquinas que
permite fabricar estos Microchips Y esto
es importantísimo
el principal fabricante de chips
nacional de China smic produce chips que
están varias generaciones por detrás de
La Vanguardia del mercado Smith
actualmente fabrica Microchips de 14
nanómetros y recientemente ha dicho que
podría fabricar pequeñas cantidades de 7
para que os hagáis una idea tsmc y
Samsung están fabricando ya ampliamente
Microchips de 5 y 3 nanómetros un
Microchips de 5 nanómetros 6
aproximadamente 3 veces más rápido o
eficiente que uno de 14
y claro para que china pueda llegar a
ese nivel necesita las máquinas que
permitan esa producción por ejemplo las
máquinas de litografía ultravioleta
extrema fabricadas por la empresa
holandesa aml la empresa más avanzada
del mundo en este campo pero ahora sin
embargo china ya no podrá Comprar ese
tipo de tecnología lo que puede retrasar
en una década o más sus planes esta
queridos amigos amigas son sanciones que
ya están en marcha Pero la pregunta es
se podría o se debería ir mucho más allá
si por ejemplo sillín Sigue avanzando en
su agenda hostil o incluso toma medidas
contra Taiwán realmente que persigue la
administración biden con política Pues
bien vayamos por partes
como podéis ver en pantalla Existen
varios tipos de sanciones pero lo que
aquí respecta a las dos más importantes
las dos que tendrían más sentido y más
impacto serían las sanciones financieras
y los controles a la exportación Como
por ejemplo los controles a la
exportación de bienes tecnológicos que
ya hemos visto Pues bien respecto a las
sanciones financieras Estados Unidos
podría amenazar con congelar los activos
de China tal y como ya he hecho con
Rusia China tiene algo más de tres
billones de dólares en reservas en
Estados Unidos y otros países aliados
sin embargo esto a medio plazo podría
ser una malísima idea primero porque
reduciría la atracción de capitales y
por otro porque china podría reaccionar
confiscando las inversiones occidentales
En el país hablamos según los datos del
centro de estudios estratégicos
internacionales de unos 3,6 billones de
dólares de inversión directa y 2,2
billones en acciones bonos y productos
similares luego otro tipo de sanciones
financieras sería cortar la operativa de
sus bancos con los bancos
internacionales esto sería algo así como
el botón nuclear El problema es que se
hundiría el comercio con China si no se
pueden pagar los intercambios de bienes
estos pues lógicamente no se van a
producir incluso introducir
restricciones menores como la exclusión
de Swift tendría un impacto considerable
para china pero también para los propios
occidentales que de repente se
encontrarían con una escasez enorme de
todo tipo de productos sería un caos
total muchas empresas occidentales
colapsarían y la inflación sería por las
nubes pensad que china es el mayor
exportador del mundo y que produce
tantas cosas como Estados Unidos y
Europa juntos Así que no no parece una
buena idea y eso nos lleva directamente
a las sanciones comerciales a los
aranceles y a la restricción de las
importaciones
[Música]
Pues bien los aranceles no son muy
eficientes y acaban pagando el pato y la
factura los propios consumidores
occidentales de hecho según las
estimaciones de la reserva Federal de
Nueva York los aranceles de Trump
costaron una media de 830 dólares
anuales por hogar estadounidense Así que
eso nos deja solo con dos medidas
posibles dos medidas mucho más graduales
y quirúrgicas primero reducir
progresivamente el peso de china en las
cadenas de producción internacional El
problema es que esto es un proceso muy
largo Así que sobre todo la opción pasa
pues por restringir el acceso del
gigante asiático a determinadas
importaciones pero aquí hay que ser muy
selectivos porque las fábricas de China
tienen que seguir produciendo y además
habría que evitar a toda costa el
conflicto no olvidemos que china es una
potencia nuclear con planes muy pero que
muy claros fijaos china estudia
triplicar su arsenal de cabezas
nucleares hasta 900 en 2035 mientras se
prevé una nueva escalada de las
tensiones con Estados Unidos por Taiwán
así que por ejemplo bloquear su
suministro de petróleo pues no tendría
mucho sentido finaría la producción
china crearía una crisis mundial y
quizás Incluso un choque militar por eso
hay que ser mucho más selectivos y es un
problema que china sea la fábrica del
mundo no el problema en todo caso que
sea una potencia tecnológica de primer
nivel y sabéis que en este aspecto china
sigue siendo muy pero que muy
dependiente
[Música]
sí china exporta muchísimo pero también
se traga una enorme cantidad de
productos del extranjero sin ir más
lejos su principal importación Además
del petróleo son los Microchips y los
productos tecnológicos avanzados y
quiénes son sus principales proveedores
pues ya os digo yo que Japón Corea del
Sur Estados Unidos Taiwán Alemania Y
algún otro país occidental dominan la
inmensa mayor parte de las importaciones
tecnológicas de China de esta forma
restringir el acceso a la tecnología de
vanguardia podría ser un golpe muy duro
para las ambiciones de que se pusiera en
riesgo el papel actual de china en la
economía mundial no tener acceso a la
tecnología de vanguardia podría sin ir
más lejos limitar la capacidad militar
del gigante asiático y Sí eso es
exactamente lo que explica la estrategia
de la administración biden y las
restricciones tecnológicas te habías
parado a pensarlo
pero sintetizando se puede entonces
sancionar a China Pues con carácter
general Lo cierto es que no el remedio
podría llegar a ser peor que la
enfermedad y el caos sería generalizado
digamos que el papel de china la
economía mundial se ha vuelto demasiado
importante ahora bien lo que sí se puede
hacer es ralentizar su desarrollo
impidiendo su acceso a tecnologías y
productos de vanguardia además esto
haría que muchas empresas trasladarán
poco a poco sus cadenas de producción
fuera de China y a largo plazo puede ser
la mejor opción para no depender de los
Caprichos de shipping o dictadores
parecidos que existan alternativas claro
que el problema es que esto requiere
tomar medidas cuanto antes y no esperar
a un posible choque porque en un plazo
de tiempo corto estas medidas no serían
efectivas
por supuesto Estados Unidos y sus
aliados tendrían también que pisar el
acelerador para promover su desarrollo
tecnológico esto probablemente requiera
de nuevos incentivos a las empresas en
la inversión una política activa del
gobierno y una puerta mucho más abierta
para la atracción de talento
internacional y sí china podría intentar
ponerse a la par pero el problema es que
sigue estando muy por detrás sufre una
norma de fuga de talentos y además el
peso de las grandes empresas públicas
que son mucho menos innovadoras que las
privadas y está volviendo a crecer en su
economía es decir que esta estrategia
realmente podría llegar a funcionar
Incluso si no disuada al gobierno chino
de su agenda al menos podría limitar su
capacidad de maniobra esto al menos es
lo que parecen pensar en Washington y lo
que explica los últimos movimientos de
Estados Unidos Pero ha llegado hasta
aquí la pregunta es para ti crees que
esta es una buena estrategia crees que
quieres restringir aún más el acceso de
China a la tecnología occidental sería
una respuesta suficiente para así Jean
Pink que podría hacer en ese caso el
gobierno chino déjanos en los
comentarios sus impresiones y abramos
debate y ahora si este vídeo se resultó
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like y suscribiros si es que aún no
lo habéis hecho una vez más Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]